an 11 year old girl from a British
family who was shot dead in France has
been named as Selen Thornton
she was playing in the garden of her
home in San herbo a village in Brittany
on Saturday evening according to French
media her father was also attacked and
is in a critical condition our
correspondent the lane of eslani which
joins me now with more details in Malena
what do we know about what happened here
well this incident happened on Saturday
around 10 p.m according to local media
reports the family were having a
barbecue they were out in their Garden
when their 71 year old Dutch neighbor
emerged shooting towards them and in
that event tragically the 11 year old
girl lost her life we now have her name
her name was Selen and her father who
has also now being named as Adrian
Thornton now he has been badly injured
as well and he's in a critical condition
in hospital her mother Rachel Thornton
also injured but her injuries are not
thought to be life-threatening now the
only person to emerge unharmed was their
eight-year-old daughter Celeste Thornton
she ran off to the neighbors alerting
them to what had happened and reportedly
she had told them that her sister was
dead now the 71 year old neighbor the
suspect then went back to his house
where she he shot himself with his wife
so the French police and the Tactical
units in a negotiator were on scene
trying to coax him out eventually he was
arrested his wife is also now being held
but a truly shocking event in this
rather quiet corner of Brittany we do
know that the family had lived in France
for a while both girls are thought to
have been born there according to locals
they had lived in their house for about
four to five years but they were very
well known in the community the local
mayor said that they would attend the
Village vet regularly that they were a
family that never caused any problems
now there were perhaps some suggestions
that there could have been a dispute
between neighbors but it's hard to
imagine what could have happened to have
led to such an escalation and such a
young child losing her life now we know
that the far and Commonwealth
development offers are in touch with the
family providing their assistance